a sentencing hearing begins this morning
for a former police officer convicted of
manslaughter after shooting a black
woman in her home Aaron Dean faces up to
20 years in prison for the killing
recorded on police body cam video Dean
was charged with murder for shooting at
Tiana Jefferson through a window while
investigating a call from a concerned
neighbor Omar via Franca first covered
this story in 2019 and has our report on
yesterday's verdict
wait for Omar's package there this is
the jury find the defendant Aaron York
Dean guilty of the offensive
manslaughter former Fort Worth police
officer Aaron Dean showed no emotion as
the verdict was read it comes more than
three years after Dean shot 28 year old
to Tatiana Jefferson inside her home
officers came to her home after a
neighbor reported Jefferson's door was
open body cam video showed officers
responding but never identifying
themselves
seconds after Dean spots Jefferson
through her window put your hands up
show me your answer
she was shot as her then eight-year-old
nephew stood watching Dean later
resigned and on the stand argued he was
acting in self-defense I just saw the
silhouette of the person and the gun I
don't recall seeing hands but I did see
that weapon pointed at me but
Jefferson's nephew now 11 years old told
a different story I was thinking is it a
dream she was crying just shaking he
testified his aunt went to the window
after hearing a noise outside and said
she did not Point her gun before she was
shot and fell to the ground if you
remember if she had the gun up or down
down
down are you sure she didn't have it up
at all
he testified the door was only open
because they burned hamburgers and
wanted to air out the house manslaughter
is without the intent to kill he
intended to kill her family and friends
say the manslaughter conviction is not
enough totally disappointed because
Justice have not been served for CBS
mornings I'm Omar villafranca in Fort
Worth